Android makes it easy to incorporate
translation into your app.
Here I've made a translate app, and
I'm going to make it display text
that translates automatically
to our language of interest.
In this case, we'll include
translations to Spanish and French.
So I've started with the main
activity with an empty view.
So the first thing we need to
do is to create some text,
by creating a text view.
And we can do that in our
activity main XML file.
Right now, we just have our empty
layout, so let's create a text view
that appears at the top of our screen
and displays the text hello world.
Our text view automatically gives us
our layout width and layout height.
And since I want to text to
appear at the top of our screen,
I'm going to give these dimensions
that take up the whole screen,
which is going to be wrapped content for
both.
Great, now I need one more parameter.
That's the text that this will contain.
So, I say android text equals.
Now I can put any string
I want to be displayed.
And I'll put Hello_World.
Now let's see if this worked.
It did, we see it appear right
at the top of our screen and
actually let me change the text size so
that it's bigger.
Okay, I change of text size to be 24 dp,
so that should be bigger.
Great, now it's a little more
visible and we can change this text
to anything we want just by changing
the wording in our text view.
So instead of Hello World,
I could say goodbye,
and then save it and it'll change.
But to display this in different
languages, we want to be
able to load this string from a file and
change it based on the language we want.
So we don't actually want to hard
code it in our view like we've done.
Instead, for any text we use,
we'll want to reference it from our
file that contains all our strings or
strings XML file, or strings that
are contained in our values folder.
So let's take a look at what's in there.
We already have a string called
app name that says translate,
that's the title of our app and
one for settings as well.
These were automatically generated.
So now let's make our own.
So in our strings XML file,
let's create a string with
the variable name, hello world.
Then this string tag will include
the word or phrase we want to display.
So let's just write in hello_world here.
Then we'll want to reference this
variable when we go to display our
text view.
And to reference it, we'll be using
the variable name hello_world.
So let's go back to our text view.
In antibody main,and delete
our hard coded text.
To reference a string variable in
strings to XML, we have to say @string.
And you'll see some pop up,
all the strings that are stored
In our string's XML file.
So we want to say @string then
slash the variable name we want,
which in this case is
our hello world string.
Now let's save this and
see what's displayed.
Hello world, It worked.
And loading the string instead of
writing it indirectly makes it easy for
us to include different languages.
For example,
to include the string in Spanish, you
just have to open a translation editor.
Up here we click on the little
world icon, and edit translations.
We see all our string variables,
action settings, app name, and
hello world which I'm going to focus on.
So to add a Spanish
translation to hello world,
I just click on this world icon again.
And you can see all of these options for
different languages.
So I'll scroll all
the way down to Spanish.
And when I click it, these boxes
appear under a Spanish option.
Our app name will stay
the same unless we change it.
And we have to include translations for
Settings, and
hello world, and
any other strings we added.
So let's include a Spanish
translation for hello world.
We go down here to the translation
box and type in our translation.
Instead of hello world,
we'll have hola mundo.
And let's add one more
type of translation.
Let's add a French one.
So again we go to a world icon and
scroll down to French.
And we have another column appearing for
the French language.
And I'll write my translation.
Instead of hello world,
I'll have bonjour tu la monde.
And so, all these different translations
are now assigned to a same
string variable, hello_world.
Then, for any devices that are in
Spanish or French our app will check in
here for any Spanish resources or
French resources.
And if it can't find any,
it will go back to a default value.
And it's the same process for
any other languages you want to add.
So localization can
be as simple as that.